so next up i'm going to have a chat to a
guy that we had up on stage earlier just
to refresh your memory uh this is his
google chrome ad that current uh look
has had seven million views
i'm just a kid
some are calling it poetry sp tv
is
every day
um
to give you more of an idea of what
jamal's all about he once convinced his
agent that me and him are cousins
it's not bad not bad i think his agent
still believes that um so
do you keep a close either no you're in
you're in the music space in in a big
way um do you keep a close eye on
technical tech developments in that area
or do you just keep doing what you're
doing um i try and keep my
when i first started i kept my eyes on
everything too much which actually
affected what sb tv was i remember when
i i i was trying to branch out of doing
underground music and i was waiting
outside i made for a hotel for kelly
rowland and um as we went in there mtv
was and i was quite fascinated about mtv
set up their shoots of all the cameras
the
equipment everything and
after that i sort of that was the big
turning point in stock china focus on
other things and letting in all these
other things and always said like chase
the dream is not a competition and i was
always looking at the competition trying
to like think how i can be better than
him and not actually focusing on what i
had myself but now i try and keep it
here to the ground or i've got people
around me that sort of
download everything on the internet and
then just told me what's going on really
yeah but i still try to keep my head to
the ground when did you first realize
that svtv was going to blow up in a big
way
when i could leave my top man job yeah
i was a good indicator
i was working it was mad because
i was saying earlier like i've got it's
a 360. i've now got a range of
self-belief hats on top man and it was
like
when i was working i got a job at 16 and
um i did a two weeks work experience
first
and then my youtube check started coming
in and well i said to my mom look i've
got like hundreds of pounds let me leave
tomorrow's that no it's not sustainable
income what is youtube well this and i
was like please like if i leave i can
build it and keep on building it and i
think i've got a check which is as much
as what i was getting in top men and i
was like look man please and then she
finally uh let me free i love the idea
you're just begging to lay the top like
yeah
you know what top man actually as a
person let me uh
made me much more open than what i was i
was quite a closed person and i i went
to the internet to sort of um voice my
opinion because i didn't feel like
anyone wanted to listen to what i said
and that's why i started my youtube
channel but in talk man you had to go
out to random people that you never met
and said you want a store card and that
was like the most frightening thing ever
and like it was just like that helped i
definitely think topman has been a part
of my uh journey
um what has given you your your business
savvy did you always knew that you had
it or
um i think it's just from soaking up uh
everything um i say i'm like a sponge i
try and soak everything up and give it
back to my audience and there's loads of
events that i do like literally just got
back from monaco from the world
entrepreneurial event and i met like so
many people like and i soaked that all
up and that's what sort of has
made me brand myself more as an
entrepreneur because people used to look
at me and not really think that i could
be an entrepreneur but i always say now
i said did you want to
digipreneur i'm a digital entrepreneur
and um i sort of just try and push that
message as much as i can but youtube has
allowed me to brand myself in a way
where it's not me being looked at as
talent but more as a businessman and
trying to keep on scaling business
and do you think that a big part of your
success was being an early adopter
because you got on youtube in 2006 right
yeah when i was about 15
and that's when i first opened it and i
say yeah there was a gap in the market
but i always look at
content now of having like the six
shareable factors like either being
entertaining
funny scary
uh
not covered by the mainstream media
nostalgic or something else and i always
said if my content hits at least two of
those which at that time was
entertaining and not being covered by
the mainstream media i can um build a
business off the back of it so does that
mean like you say you do need to keep an
eye on that mainstream media to make
sure that you're not doing too much of a
crossover because then you lose your usp
i guess yeah like trying to keep the
balance and that's what i'm trying to do
at the moment is try and
do
the underground stuff but also do a
little bit of mainstream stuff but an
underlying message that i try and put
through everything is self-belief so
some a person overcoming their problems
or a person trying to inspire
self-belief and that that can be applied
to music fashion comedy sport business
and that's what hopefully i'm going to
do for like the next 10 years maybe
everyone says i always look at the power
of now but everyone says what's your
five-year tenure and i just think yeah
well it's just like building just get on
me now
i used to get lost in the future and not
actually focusing on what i had
in front of me and that was like a big
lesson that i learned
what have you made of um the recent
emergence of things like tidal and
apple's new music service
um
i think it's very exciting but i still
think i come out i'm trying to think of
an angle of all these other i look at
dave and goliath they're like the huge
companies and there's obviously like a
small company that might overtake them
but with sort of the bigger companies
it's always the talent that you attach
to it so i'm always trying to find
talent before they even hit tidal or
apple's um
sort of awareness of the artist so i i
don't know it's very exciting i think it
just needs a bit of a buzz in the music
scene so and allegedly very different to
the way that apple are going about it
yeah um
i think yeah i did say allegedly so i'm
okay um so
um your success has led to
a lot of other opportunities outside of
the sort of core business of svtv do you
feel a lot of responsibility because
you're kind of held up as being this
voice of the youth in a way aren't you
yeah
um
more recently i've sort of taken it on
board like in a space of today i'd like
an email from
uh the secretary of state for the uk and
michelle obama's coming over next week
they want me to make a video about
getting more girls into education and
this stuff happens like every week and
it's like in my head i'm always thinking
like less is more but i feel like i've
got a opportunity in front of me i've
got to take it and try and give it um
back to the audience but i do it in a
way where it's not
bridging the gap so like when i got
asked to
i remember i was a couple years ago i
bumped into
there was a panel and it was like ken
livingstone edibles ed miliband and i
went out to ed milburn after i want an
interview for my channel to everyone
else i think what the hell are you then
but he turned around to me and said yes
and i was using that as an opportunity
to sort of bridge the gap and
i've learned from that interview i went
there with like headphones around my ear
and like a sp tv channel i'll never do
that again i thought if that was a part
of the history but i always look at
these opportunities as trying to
use it to sort of better my audience and
and educate them in a way okay uh any
questions from the audience maybe do a
couple if anyone's got one
no
no questions for jamal yes one question
gentlemen at the back
hey jamal i i work for warner music so i
just like to say firstly thank you for
everything you do for new music and in
particular ed sheeran you gave him a
a great start so yeah that's why we love
coming to these things
just can you talk a little bit about
discovering new talent as one of the
sort of unique positions
of sb tv that is that something you look
for first and foremost um yeah i always
uh
even when i'm outside and i see people
basking on the street i always get
everyone's details because i never
have a rock unturned and i think i get a
lot of at the moment i get an influx of
people that are sending me music but i'm
always trying to focus on the up and
coming ones more than the mainstream
ones i use the mainstream ones because
it's always good to get a name on there
but i'm always trying to find a talent
before they hit the mainstream where i
find it is just from
a lot of it is in my email i've got like
50 thousand emails to still to go
through so it just like packs up but um
i don't know i guess
i'm trying to get talent from everywhere
what was your question i don't
yeah your fascination is discovering new
talent rather than amplifying the big
names yeah because everyone i think they
don't really want to hear i think
everyone cares about a big name
i look at it like if you're at home in
your bedroom and you find a a artist
that only has about 5 000 views you're
much more excited to share it to your
friends and say i shared this first then
having someone that's got millions of
views and i've just
i've taken that research in for my
audience i find that when videos are
smaller and then in three months got
hundreds of thousands of views the early
adopters are like oh my god we find it
first and that's sort of a
badge against the whole social community
of saying our refund is first we're
we're part of the journey and that's the
same for the google chrome advert when
people started watching that they feel
like they've contributed to the success
of sbtv and i always try and make sure
that i'm taking them along the journey
of them but yeah i always try and it's
always about up and coming musicians for
me yeah definitely great thank you all
right yes just one more question for
this lady here
hi jamal hello
my name is sophia and i'm from a social
news magazine called blasting news
so as a fellow media person i'm
wondering how are you bringing revenue
to your channel so are you doing normal
advertising native advertising
sponsorships
and what are your revenue generation
plans for the future
so at the moment my main
revenue is from
youtube branded content
merch and live so like the sbtv hats
when i've done the collaboration of new
era the live events we've taken over um
uh
wireless best of all
and a big part of its brand of content
which i'm now moving into a lot more
than i've done previously and i've now
got a lady who has come the big thing
that i had to overcome is the perception
of sbtv and and what can a brand do to
work with sp tv and i've recently got a
lady who's come from ipg and
vodafone has those years of experiences
she's now coming into the business i'm
going to see all these different
agencies and brands and that's the
message i'm not trying to push
forward but the main ones are live
merch branded content
consultancy is quite a big one and
looking after certain artists social
channels i guess
okay i think we're going to work we're
going to wrap it up
that's our time thank you very much to
jamal edwards